COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some tax experts gain
performance independence.
If their friends' performance
jumped off a cliff,
would they do, too?
Stay tuned to find out.
Tax Lemming is a startup focused
on making sense of purchases,
taxes, and basic bookkeeping
for your small business needs.
But they had a problem
that was keeping them
from going for their
next round of VC funding.
They've got too many
instances spinning up,
and it was breaking the bank.
See, in a rush to put
together a working prototype,
the Tax Lemming's client
hit a Google Load Balancer,
which fetched content from a
GC instance running Apache.
Now to improve performance,
their lead engineer
wanted to move to a very
traditional solution
for web-based
applications-- adding
a layer of NGINX instances to
act as a reverse caching proxy
to the Apache servers,
and then change the client
to fetch static content
directly from a CDN instead
of the back end instances.
Now this is a very
tried and true solution.
But before they started
tearing things up,
I wanted to present them
with an alternative way
to get the same caching
performance but with less
instances and lower costs
using GCP's Load Balancers.
See, one secret that GCP
Load Balancers have is that
with the click of a button--
that button-- the Load
Balancer will cache requests
and move them to
Google Cloud CDN
to reduce latency
on your behalf.
As long as the
request is cached,
it will be served directly
at Google's Network Edge
rather than going
to the back end.
Performance-wise,
this is a huge boost.
We can easily see the difference
when comparing direct access
to the resource through the
instance versus allowing
the load balancer to
cache the request.
This graph shows that once
the asset gets cached,
the response time
drops significantly.
And all you had to
do was check a box.
What's even better about this
is that the cached content
is served right from
Google CDN without any need
for caching instances to exist.
To use a new buzzword, you
could call this "serverless."
I'm cool.
Now, another nifty feature
that the load balancers
allow you to do is
create host routing paths
for your domain, which
will serve content directly
from a Google Cloud
Storage bucket.
This way you don't have
to modify the client
to fetch new types of content
from a different CDN location.
Instead, you can
just treat the assets
as though they
were subdirectories
and the load balancers
will do the right thing.
And of course, to improve
performance further,
you can even cache those
assets to the CDN, as well.
So with a few button
clicks, Tax Lemmings
was able to cut down
their instance count
and reduce their maintenance
headaches long-term.
If you'd like more
details on this problem,
check out the full article
linked in the description
below.
And make sure to subscribe
to our Google Cloud YouTube
channel to get alerts when new
performance videos comes out.
And don't forget, when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.